now we're going to talk about your play
Matthew but later because you've never
been here before there will be a couple
of friends questions okay that's fine
and just to let you know on the sofa
it's quite yin-yang Gemma Arterton over
there you lived and breathed friends I
mean you were a big fan I was the
generation of friends I mean I'm
thirteen two weeks but when I was a kid
I was in the age I had Rachel haircut
the lot oh it wasn't a good period no
and then Miriam is one of those people
you must be in such a tiny minority in
the world I've never seen friends but
that's not possible me well I wasn't
woken up in a hotel room and it was just
all I'll show you some episodes in a
hotel room
why um many years ago I lived in America
yeah in Los Angeles and I was part of
the stable of comedy people of Norman
Lear and he introduced me to Marta
Kauffman and David Crane and I really
liked David Crane and I couldn't stand
Marta Kauffman I thought she was a
monster friends
I've actually quite a lovely woman
don't say anything I want no need I'd
have thought at this point he gon tell
you know I think it's been said
and the guy at my channel on came back
from the bathroom and my friend said
that's not my Mariano life what is the
name of Chandler's father's all-male
burlesque
I actually know that - that's Viva Las
Vegas